hey man it's me kevin smith welcome
to masters of the universe revelation
celebration a celebration
of the writers of masters of the
universe and look
big writers come in small packages
ladies and gentlemen this is
dia who wrote episode two and we're
gonna
go through the entire episode uh today
now like with the others you line it up
yourself and whatnot there'll be no
image here except
us so if this image offends you you're
not going to like the next half hour
there's no he-man master universe images
or any you got to do that part yourself
this is a commentary track that that
kind of lines up with it
um that now we've gotten the disclaimers
out of the way
do you tell these fools at home when you
first knew that you were a writer
not when you wanted to be right when did
you know
your writer or have you figured it out
yet you know i don't know
that i knew i was a writer i just
remember going to the first harry potter
and
being like oh oh so someone got to go to
hogwarts
that's gonna be me one day um and that
that pretty much is it this this whole
thing is just a scam to be able to go to
hogwarts and
if you want to call me a writer if
that's the way i get my ticket sure
let's do it
i'm uh you're just you know let's just
go back for a second here so it's during
the first harry potter
movie that you're like oh i'm a writing
could happen
i hesitate to ask how old were you when
you're oh god
uh like eight i think eight or nine
so dia is our youngest writer at 16 on
the show and
it shows you that writers come in all
ages and stuff like that oh my god do
you know when i
thought about writing for the first time
when like 1980 bro
i wasn't even a i wasn't even a twinkle
in my parents
there were two other people that were
like i wonder who i'll be with one day
my parents weren't even married then
we should point out you're gonna make
him sound scandalous uh dia's mom is
watching
so i'm gonna try to watch my language
but no guarantee because that's how i
make my living
but dia won't curse at all not once
because she's a good girl
that being said in the writers room blue
streak no no
i learned new vulgarities that i've
never heard before that i still
pass on to others in the world um he's
lying
i've never i've never even heard a curse
word in my life
um i i wouldn't know what they mean
she's a good girl mom
she's good girl loves her mom
they just pulled us off of youtube right
now for that
um okay so what were you doing prior to
ma
tell them what you're doing now man if i
can flip out your big writer's [ __ ]
you know i mean tell them what you're
doing are you allowed to or is it
spoilers
i can yeah she got big job kids with a
big
place and it's it's big it's easy
you'll find out what it is when do they
announce it i think the show is
announced but i don't think the writers
are announced yet and that she's working
on
how deep are you into the writing
process uh we've
the room's been up for a month so we're
still you know working it out we had our
pitches last week
um to network and studio and is it a
real room or zoom room it's a zoom room
and i love it like you don't you can you
don't get the same vibe right so
we wrote this in your living room we did
that was our writer's room yeah
first on the couches and once around the
bar as well once around the bar
um group chat a lot of it on group chat
especially in this episode as you'll
find out i made eric uh
write some stuff for me because
i didn't want to did you really that's
pretty much it
yeah but then it got cut so it didn't
matter no no
it's all i was like we're gonna have to
break off eric a little more cash
which is something i said throughout the
entire process of writing
we're gonna have to break off eric a
little more cash um
yeah you guys were absolutely phenomenal
we had an amazing team
uh of whom thus far you've only met me
uh here you're meeting dia next up you
get to meet mark then tim
and then eric the aforementioned eric
will be joining us and stuff
but for right now line up your masters
of the universe
a revelation oh it's lined up uh
episode two the poison chalice a title
that you came
up with i did i think i'm the only one
who has their same title
is that a thing that the writers noticed
because i changed a lot of the titles it
really is actually
is it really like he [ __ ] changed my
title
some of them were like funny but they
were joke references to like the four
non blonde song and i was like like
eric's number
five i think was something like that
yeah and then i was like no no no it has
to be the forge on the forest of forever
very star trek-y but my i mean mine is
boys and girls the poison chalice is is
like a weird
plugging eric again eric and i love a
theme right
dia's mom for the record nobody's
plugging eric on this show
just it's a good clean show see what i'm
saying about
the mouth in the writer's room i'm
plugging eric what did eric do
well he knows i love a theme and so he
said
in this episode you'll find like they go
to a
mountain that shall remain unnamed
spoilers i assume they've seen it that's
my point excellent point
uh if you haven't watched the masters
universe revolution
go watch it then when you re-watch it
that's when you do this anyway so now
spoil it they go to snake mountain
and and the land is very spoilers
and uh they're there to find uh
like a goblet right and so eric sent me
this poem called the wasteland by t.s
eliot and it's the myth of the fisher
king which is arthurian legend
like like how often does somebody ever
say something like that so eric sent me
a name classic poem um and
we we love both of us really love arthur
um
king arthur legends and her and eric i i
don't care for king arthur legends
i think they're a bunch of [ __ ] my
apologies to d is mine
but like i am buying it anyway who does
he think he is
arthurian fan girl over here [ __ ]
like sword and a stone over here
so anyway what did he say but the legend
of the fisher king is about
um the king who has been
wounded gravely and the land has become
barren and percival goes to find the
holy grail
yeah and so that is what um the poem is
about
that was the next calendar no yeah sure
is i've seen a movie
and uh there's some lines in the poem
that i really wanted
to use to like frame
tila's perspective which are um
i'm gonna mess it up this is not the
actual words but it's something like
who is the third who's always walking
beside you i count you
and me but there is another who who is
always walking beside you
and so when i was writing tila because
this is the first episode post he-man i
was like
that is how i want adam's presence in
this episode
that's beautiful you gave that actual
thought like that yeah
i just write [ __ ] well done themes
ladies and gentlemen they paid me they
paid me to do so so i did it it's not
netflix
some of the hotel television money yeah
um they paid me in toys
but yeah but so especially with the
flashback like it is
and going to snake mountain and seeing
this sort of like
these old places she's been i wanted
like the specter of adam
always there in every single frame even
though he's not physically
plan a plan a writer with a plan plan
dia came into our writer's room with a
plan the first session we had
dia wasn't there and then you came in
from the second session on what had you
worked on prior magic
magic the gathering um i actually
stopped magic on
friday and then came to he-man on monday
and you came loaded for bear you brought
i mean we'll get into it in this episode
but there's like an element of this
episode
that like not only inform the rest of
the season it probably informs season
two as well
oh yes i know what you're talking about
but okay
of course you do oh yes oh yes
yes your mother's not the only mother
that we'll be talking about in this
episode it's
true i certainly planned that let's uh
let's
let's dive in shall we line up your
episodes kids if you want to watch along
uh or you can just watch two people
talking and enjoying their own work in a
gross way
i know we're supposed to be ashamed of
what we've done but like i love this
show
i mean it's my first episode here we go
now is this your first
uh there's the netflix logo ba-bomb um
is
was this your f now you worked on magic
the gathering is it out yet
no so this is the first thing that will
ever be out of mind
oh my god you're right the first thing
that will ever be out like yeah
this will you'll never forget your first
how awesome and solo writing credit
i may add pretty hot tell them what that
means
to you know people who aren't in our
business
having a solo writing i mean it means
i've arrived i think
that right i don't actually know does it
mean it means i get all the money is
what it means number one she gets paid
number two she gets credit that's the
nice thing and stuff could be vice versa
but a lot of people sometimes like
work do their best work there look at
that look at her and
somewhere dia's mom is just like oh i
knew it
i knew it from birth which came out a
new writer i says
um this uh for those that uh are looking
kind of close
uh i just found this out from adam and
pat
our directors last night uh we all had a
party
or teddy had a party at his house and we
all went and so the boys from powerhouse
came out and they said those masks
are also they're like there's so many
easter eggs in this oh
those masks are a reference to something
else now damn uh
let's see oh look at this there it is
jason muse ladies and gentlemen best
character
type cast of stinkour first stink or in
cartoon uh form i believe and you know
what he deserves it
right he's been waiting his turn stinkor
is is badly maligned i think
um you know just because a guy stinks
like let him let him be
that's trendy now hey man sometimes
deodorant's not enough for some of us
he he's using like like the vegan
organic so it's edible but it ain't good
it's edible
because he cares about the environment
jason mu is representing highlands new
jersey as stingcore ladies and gentlemen
um pride the pride of jersey there he
falls you can hear him go snooze
as he falls really yeah um okay so
now let me tell you a story episode one
which i wrote was so long that they had
to
make like cuts for time so so i didn't
write this actually
kind of there's a certain point where
dia stuff kicks in
but all this [ __ ] right here this is
still
from episode one so because
you know netflix and mattel television
were like
there now now we're in my episode are we
yeah
no you start with the yeah do we start
with this we start here
but no glove no love is mine i think we
start with
uh the flashback because the plan was
right yes every episode was gonna start
with a flashback so two
three start a flashback but then because
of what happened with episode one being
so long
they hacked off the last whatever five
ten pages and [ __ ]
and that began episode one which
everybody felt was kind of like you know
what the
like the break where tila walks away
from the palace
like rather than do fade to black and
then do one year later or something like
that they're like that
feels like the episode end so that was
not
like it wasn't like oh her [ __ ]
script sucks so let's put half of mine
in it or something like that it was just
it had to move over but by virtue of
that you want to talk about
the unkindest cut and [ __ ] like the
wisdom of solomon
like having to cut a baby in the half
yes there is a character
that dia wrote an amazing scene for was
a character's name
eileena who i love i love eileena from
the original
and there's a big fight with her and
tila yes
at the at right before they're gonna go
uh to the
to the sorceress um you find out that
randor has basically
had a few guards who swore an oath to
to protect the land and they are led by
eileena who as we know
looked up to tila in the original series
and there's a whole episode about that
and she learned from tila about bravery
and tila has to fight her and it was so
it was like me doing what i would want
as a fan which is like
really carrying over these lessons and
having to face it
and it was voiced by my own daughter
wow that's like you know one of those
stories of moses or whatever
the [ __ ] where you know because god told
me to sacrifice his son he goes doing
god's like oh
just kidding don't worry about it that
that i heard the lord tell me sacrifice
your child's part
in masters of the universe for the
better for the betterment of the whole
program and so i did we had to cut her
out which was such a bummer
and it was such a great scene and i will
forever
bump into like not in a bad way where
i'm like [ __ ] this project
but i will forever bump into the fact
that when they do go to
castle grace call which at that point is
the palace of wisdom
they just walk in there's like nobody
guarding it or anything like that
and we just play it as like the
abandoned zone and [ __ ] here
is the official start yes where dia
starts earning her money and it was it
was
like mosquito was going to be in it it
was a whole thing
and it was like a big battle because how
can you have taylor go back to snake
mountain and not remember adam right
yes of course and this move that's right
you had mosquito or at one point
it was an aerial battle i was just like
burning through that animation
yeah and those cats were like we got a
lot to do man how about
he just fights whiplash and then we'll
move on uh the idea here
it was oh this move they'll repeat in
many many times throughout the show
it'll happen again too
um well she'll repeat it with andra
later in this episode and then she
repeats it with adam in episode five
so um the idea when we were putting the
show together was
since you know as you saw in episode one
spoilers if you didn't watch episode one
he-man is sacrifices himself uh
at the right of the head of the story
you know naturally
we want he-man in our show it's masters
universe he's one of the main characters
just like tila so
we kept him alive so to speak until
episode
five or the end of episode four um by
way of the flashback so when you look at
their first appearance at wolfgate
it has a different animated style to it
it's a little more
innocent and it's there's not technology
there then we did
the dissolve and suddenly you see all
the tech and the idea
in the writer's room was that oh it's
it's coming
sorry i got it i gotta wait for it do it
go ahead
all right it's not coming
where is it what are you waiting for my
lord of the rings reference
the one there it is snake mountain has
but one weakness
i'm glad we stopped the car for that
kids
because there's a real pilot going in if
you look out the window to the left
the grand canyon well we have we have
the
two towers and so i tried to get every
goddamn two towers reference i could
into this
until tim and eric were like you gotta
stop you gotta you gotta write some of
the words
you tim and eric i don't know about mark
so much but you tim and eric were the
hardcore
rings nerds and like since we were doing
a
fellowship story where like a bunch of
people get together and go on a quest
you know naturally that was a point of
reference for the kids
not for me because i'm not a big rings
guy and stuff so
it was nice to have that influence
because if i was just by myself
there would be none of that rings
nonsense i know but it would be still
thy heart and [ __ ]
so uh once again like collaboration led
to a better
way better series the uh notion uh
that since magic was gone we wanted to
turn everybody into like but not
everybody but a big portion
of eternia into like uh magic phobes uh
people that are just like we're
embracing
technology magic and technology we're
always a big part of the
masters of the universe mythos the first
reference to motherboard right there
where did the motherboard come from
writer's room did you just come up with
the name no i i just
i just came up with it so you're like i
was like computer terms
no give me some words this now the first
pass of the script
you like remember triclops and trapdraw
were like
completely different they were it was
much more the odd couple and we
it was played a little more comedically
then the next draft
dia turned it into a cult yeah well like
[ __ ]
you know indiana jones temple of doom uh
[ __ ]
race with the devil um any movie
where you see like a bunch of people
[ __ ] eyes wide shut to some degree
although none of the sex whatsoever
any movie where you see a bunch of
people gathered and like ominously oh
and [ __ ] like that that was kind of the
plan and this is what
she gave us man so and you know my note
on this
well again it's coming up but my note on
this
was uh this is this show is not rated r
yes so yeah dia went hard when i
originally wrote it i wrote like blood
splatter and you see
faces like peeled off and and you get
that and
the powerhouse people like i didn't
realize how
great they are i mean because i don't
know anything about animation right but
they
get the same level of fear and like
creepiness and body horror
and they don't need blood yes and i was
like look at look at this my crutch
your script was like just bathed in
blood
like this happens and this happens it
was body horror because this is like
body horror right like all sudden these
people are
becoming kind of cybernetic and whatnot
based on drinking
from motherboard the motherboard really
like
captured teddy's imagination so much so
that we kept it alive you'll see it in
the second half as well
and you'll if zore's willing there's a
second season there's a good chance
motherboard will be coming back um so
the idea of the
snake mountaineers who were left behind
in the wake of the death of skeletor
um you know turning it into
a techno cult where they you know
worship
technology machinery blah blah blah um
gave us something to do with our
characters because our story is kind of
about
what happens when you remove the two
pillars what happens when the guy who
everybo all the good guys or a whole
[ __ ]
being is centered around them and of the
bad guys their entire [ __ ] lives are
centered around him
what if they're removed from the board
who are these people how do they
identify themselves
how do you feel the vacuum um especially
when tila steps out of
her responsibilities and now she has to
see what's what she has let happen
um and that was the point of the well
done [ __ ] i could have used you while
i was doing press
that's well put thanks is that what we
said in the writer's room
ah that's your take on it i like your
take yeah no we said it we
we um we wanted tila to basically like
watch the father
choose this because she thought it was
something evil but this is what
people have turned towards in the
absence of
her um and the absence of he-man and she
really feels it in this episode i think
because
you got to have like his ghost there
excellent well [ __ ] put for heaven's
sakes you should go out and do all our
press
um of course uh try klopp's is being
voiced by the great
henry rollins and you had no idea when
you were writing your dialogue that
would be in rollins mouth
rollins takes it so big in this and he
asked me while we were recording he's
like please tell people that you told me
to go this big
his performance because he's done
animated voice over before i mean
um most people know but his his
performance is very subdued and i kept
pushing and i was like
henry like you're a mad monk bring it up
like just you could go as big
there's no wrong go as big as you want
um
and he was absolutely delightful dedrick
bader who plays our king randor
also plays uh trap jaw so good
i mean also like just this fight is just
phenomenal this is the fighty fighty
that they just were like
let us go ham on it we'll do it like
don't worry that's the patrick patrick
and adam our two directors
were always telling us like you know
don't you don't have to write
every action beat so much just write
fighty-fighty like we got ideas we'll
take care of it that's so they're so
good at it
like i've watched this i've watched this
like three or four times and it's the
part where
not the not the words i'm just watching
the action at this point
like i can watch this all day which is
compelling as [ __ ] what is it like
for a writer um like any writer but in
your case
a baby writer to see like oh [ __ ] i
wrote like that
i literally wrote that line where he
steps there and she and they grab hands
and like
call back what is it like yeah like what
is it like to see
it's one thing to know the tropes and
know the language of screenwriting
trade what is it like to see you wrote
something and somebody actually did it
insane it's not true it's i mean it
feels like i'm
watching harry potter and the visual in
my head
is now on screen um oh and another thing
for for specifically the snake mountain
sequence so
and the trap the trapdoor yes
everyone says there's trap door in snake
mountain and no one tells you where it
is
and so i watched like 30 hours of toy
unboxings
um and i think it was like pixel dan
finally had one where he was like
and that's i was like oh there it is
because i wanted people to be able to
open up the snake mountain toy
and be able to do this exact sequence
like from the jaw
down to the to this like weird lake
thing
and then have the sea monsters come out
because
those are like illustrated inside and
and be able to basically
play the sequence outs on the toy
oh awesome man like that's commitment to
the [ __ ] form
kids she could have literally just been
like yeah they [ __ ] run and blah blah
instead she's like you know what like
just like every
every beat of this [ __ ] show extra
thought went into like
what would someone who loved this [ __ ]
appreciate
so that's how you get to a sequence
where as they're
as you play at snake mountain you can
literally reenact it like the old
[ __ ] commercials
i mean that that's what everyone wants
to do you do only get this for my first
episode
and then from now on i'm like then you
stop
you're like you know what i did it once
good enough yeah thank you got my effort
um magestra is uh like a reference too
there's so many references in this
she uh uh evelyn over the course of the
four thousand episodes of he-man in the
masters universe
uh disguised herself as an old woman
majestro at one point so since we wanted
to
keep it under wraps uh you know until
what happens next that it's evil in
uh the idea was all right let's she's
gonna be an old woman then
the beautiful thing about motu is that
anything you think about doing
like there's this big motu encyclopedia
you could like
look for the parallel that has already
happened
or the character has already been
established and build upon it
which makes it more fun and enjoyable
for like
not everybody oh [ __ ] world's not
going to be like majestra
that's my [ __ ] jam but like two
people
out of [ __ ] 10 000 are gonna be like
that's [ __ ] dope i remember the
magestra episode man like i'm already
seeing the reaction base time we put up
the
the trailer yeah yesterday so many
people go on hardcore geek about the
splitting of the sword
yes uh that that's the thing though like
the reason you want to do this for the
show is because
the original like it rewards fans yeah
so well and so we had to in we had to
include that element
yes because that that i mean this is
just fun right you just want to have fun
you want to have your toys out you want
to
be able to play these this like
shakespearean epic
and so we really didn't have a choice
you
i just it occurs to me as i'm looking at
this that
dia is the first one to write andra or
andre depending who says it
um that you're the first one she's not
in episode one so i didn't write
for andra okay between this she fought
eileena yes
this was where the the fight was and
eileena like
gets beaten and she says she looks up at
tila and says
i used to look up it to you and tila
goes it looks like you still
do and then walks away it was a pretty
dope line
um yeah and my kid recorded too oh my
gosh wait do you have that somewhere i
want to watch it
colette has it colette's got the clutter
you know our casting director
um she's got it she's got i
as we talk about it i don't even know if
i told the kid she's cut oh
i mean it wasn't for lack of talent she
was wonderful but it's like
no i think you did last night i was i
think you did at the party
did i mention yeah what the [ __ ] are you
about what are you doing at the party if
you're not in this you should go home
she's like you brought me you [ __ ] we
certainly talked about it so i hope she
knew before then
right good point um this was uh
a teddy note because uh we in your draft
and in our
note session you know in the story in
the writer's room session
they didn't know it was evil in until
the magic happened but
teddy was such a hardcore fan of this
[ __ ] that he was like
bro there's no way that tila wouldn't
know that that was evil in the whole
time i'm like she looks like an old
woman she's gonna sound different he
goes
teal is much smarter than that having
that guy in our corner
having rob david in our corner like
meant you could never really [ __ ] up
i've referred to it as like
uh bumper bowling like when you take
kids bowling and they put the
[ __ ] bumpers in the gutters we
couldn't [ __ ] gutter a ball because
we were always hitting pins because
these guys were like you can't do that
or you should do this or
throwing in magic like a very big
collaborative effort
i tried to get another little rings
reference
in that bit because i was what are you
trying to get a job with tolkien
he's dead man move on there's amazon
yeah they're going to have to sure
good point good point you can put this
in front of amazon be like look i can
write fake spear as well as anybody else
but it was tila gonna be like her staff
i told you to take the witch's stuff
it's a little on the nose i mean why why
didn't you just have her say you
shall not pass i'm sure nobody would
notice that sure i tried at some point
they
like really were like all right you have
to write some of the words
um as you can see uh this is a very
um female heavy episode yes
so naturally in the writer's room we
were like we should write episode two
we all looked at the female and we were
like
you have to speak for all women here you
go
have fun um and you absolutely did a
blast
this is my feeling about this show um
is like i love my script for episode one
i love episode one
but i i honestly believe this about the
show every episode
is better than the previous episode so
when i watch this i'm like
same with the commentary you got him
next and he
it keeps going up it escalates um it was
it really like as i watched it i was
like oh my god like i'm more in group
like mine is a
episode one is like half of it is it's
an old show
and then the other half is like right
like when you realize
oh [ __ ] but this is where the quest
begins and you wrote this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like i you know i know a lot of people
are like [ __ ] exposition
that's some of my favorite [ __ ]
dialogue right so you have like
lena heady we didn't know we were gonna
get her when we were doing this although
in the writers room we were all like
[ __ ] evelyn should be cersei and [ __ ]
and lo and behold she did get to be but
you get to write
all this [ __ ] dialogue that like the
actors get to like spit out
set the whole thing up like this is my
favorite part
because it's like this sets us on the
journey and [ __ ] so
i do okay we had a version an early
draft
of this where i didn't realize being bad
at rhyming
was something you could be bad at but we
originally had all this exposition
coming out as the spirit of gray skull
that's right in in and this is the part
that was from nail polish erika didn't
write it for me
but he definitely gave me notes because
he loves he loves rhyming
um and he's good at it and my rhyming
was like you know like
our magic fails swirling down eternity's
drain
to like fill the plug you and like stop
the leak
you have to like unite it was so bad
it was so bad and uh what did eric do
eric eric
and either it probably was just because
they read
my draft and we're like or we never meet
that character again
and so i had finally finished i finally
finished
and you go yeah let's just cut the
character
yes okay
let's talk about cringer you wrote the
cringer [ __ ] monologue oh my god
which literally makes people cry like
people have i
reported like oh my god a green cat made
me [ __ ] cry how'd you do it
she wrote some beautiful words and
steven root delivered them with more
soul i mean than most people have in the
real world
um the uh do you know do you remember
who named me cringer is a very
like bear mccreary starts his score
there man
and it just like penetrates so deeply
and it's impossible not to cry when bear
mccreary is like doing his thing
yes and now for cringer you might have
noticed i might have said it in episode
one you'll see it in other episodes for
sure
uh cringer speaks uh about cat doesn't
battle catches wars and stuff because it
felt like
stephen i love this moment here where
he's just like i knew adam's big secret
sure
it's like all right humble brag humble
bragger
but um let me remind you of that yes
where she's like
yeah thanks buddy it's kind of why i
hate being here right now
look at that man your dialogue broke
buffy good kid that's it i'm done
um were you a buffy fan growing up so
getting sarah
as tila which oh i don't like
here i'll be honest with you in the
writers room that like
the kids and when i say the kids it's
like everybody but me
all like hardcore buffy fans who watched
the [ __ ] show so while we were doing
this there was always talk of like
what if sarah michelle gellar did it and
um you know it was that thing where
you you we wrote it sort of in a vacuum
right and then
look at all those all that estrogen and
then you cut to the
mannest of all men's literally in his
name
oh one eye there it is man as if like
people like who
is it who is that masked character um
bear's score is wonderful because it
gives you a preview of like what's to
come
and of the next and then it changes and
then it changes but the idea of course
is that um like here the fellowship has
begun like with this
you know in that pullback shot like the
players have been gathered they're gonna
gather some [ __ ] more in the next
episode
and we're off to the races so his piece
is very like energetic
and whatnot he uh i think he too was a
was a rings referencer as well it's very
weird to be on
a project where everybody's making
references to [ __ ] you're like well
i mean i kind of oh i didn't know that i
kind of remember it didn't
not weird where i was like and i hated
it it was the worst experience in my
life but it is weird where people were
like oh wait we could do this we could
do this and then
blah blah and they have all the language
and [ __ ] and i'm like you were like sure
yeah it's like if it makes you happy the
uh my geekdom only goes so far man
i ain't token it um this
was episode two ladies and gentlemen and
this
is the person uh who put it together the
writer
if you will man um who if you liked it
if you didn't it was his fault
yeah at least the first few minutes
sucked but the rest of it got [ __ ]
good um what uh you look
now we introduced motherboard in this
episode
and you'll hear more reference and see
some motherboard action later on down
the road and whatnot
um what you got now from the moment
we're in the writer's room and then we
start writing scripts and blah blah blah
you know there's always the hope that we
get to do again have you started
thinking about what you would do
if we get to do it again with
motherboard yes really
yes yes i could spoil it
no she's like i don't [ __ ] i don't
write until i'm paid i will say
uh i'm gonna rely on powerhouse to do
some
more of their cool body horror in my
opinion
and more lord of the rings just always
yeah i'm not like oh that's
that's incredibly original what is that
everyone's like that's not bro
i'll take credit it's fine um you did a
great job thank you fantastic [ __ ]
job
wait until you find out the show she's
working on now you'll be like what a
glow-up
but um we uh we got the benefit of
passion of a of a new writer man like
you know we you know
you get old ass jaded writers they're
like phoning it in
the [ __ ] went above and beyond
beyond had themes
going where i gave none i was not like
this is about this i was like just you
know
25 pages when you can and you did what
you did well you brought us all together
and everyone was so into it and we all
you know we we kept talking about it
right even outside the room and these
things
coalesce and become bigger and hopefully
a lot of people enjoy it
i hope people have fun i hope someone
actually recreates that sequence with
toys that would be my
figures yeah the snake mountain battle i
bet now that you've asked for it i
guarantee you somebody does it and puts
it up on youtube
she worked so hard for [ __ ] sake um
listen d is the one you want to thank
for episode two here we celebrate
writers this here's the writer man give
it up for
for dia and if you're dia's mom right
now
you must be beside yourself just
moist with perspiration for pride
uh at seeing first second third born
were you only born
first first born child
ascend to the top
of the point dread all right you get it
mom should be proud
um there it is kids thank you for
hanging out
on masters of the universe uh revelation
celebration i'm kevin smith i'm dean
mishra and uh
go watch episode three you have the
power
this is the cat greetings everybody
and welcome to the aka ask kev anything
every saga has a 10-year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with jay and sam bob get old i'm
kevin smith